but i get [ __ ] yeah especially right now
the mass mandate isn't it weird they
put it back on it's unbelievable to me
and everybody's like okay
the l.a sheep are like we'll do it yeah
i thought there'd be
more of an uproar you know it's amazing
to me
nothing it's a it's it depends on what
you
listen to we have a friend let me say
anything we have a friend who wants to
bet me a hundred grand that we get
locked down in november again
and he's like look at the recall they're
doing the recall they moved up september
because they lock you down november like
[ __ ]
but they'd have the only way they'd lock
you down in november is if they could
justify the number of deaths and the
over see
it's all about overwhelming the health
care system yeah yeah
so but you got to figure in in the
winter the cold's gonna come back
they like to contribute that to cove but
no matter what right
so yeah could get dicey that
yeah that i don't know do we lock down
again i'll i just i can't
i can't no i cannot that'd be that'd be
the straw in the camera sometimes it's
worth getting arrested for
passive resistance i mean
i guess dude what are you fighting what
are you gonna do you're making a
statement and you get a group of people
that come into places public areas
without masks and you sit down
i mean good luck with that bubba it
works no it doesn't it does
no it doesn't pass the resistance works
they've tried to all last lockdown
restaurants
enough people do it you do it you have a
bunch of people who did it in a target
here in california do you remember
they were like yelling at people in the
target for wearing masks and trying to
rip them off mm-hmm
some of that the the government's not
going to bend to that
you you'd have to be like mass amount of
people
what has to happen is they have what
when you make enough of a spectacle
they have to justify because what
happens then is the
the politicians and health bureaucrats
put on the spot to justify
why these lockdowns are happening with
so much civil unrest
and then then what happens is you don't
have enough civil unrest
well that's how you put pressure on
people on your elected officials if you
have civil unrest
and we don't have civil unrest that's
the number one ingredient we need and we
don't have that
everyone's cool with it that's right if
you've been not cool with it then knew
something's like oh [ __ ] i don't need
this that's just you on a recall i don't
need this
i agree but also the the what
for people not in california you gotta
understand the state of california
saying the mandate doesn't make any
sense not backed by science
it's just the county of los angeles
that's what's
nuts it's incredible and then the it's
almost like they want the power they get
it's the power
sadistic and then the lapd was like
we're not enforcing this
like again this isn't backed by science
we're not enforcing any of these rules
so technically you don't have to but l.a
county sheriff won't enforce new mass
media not backed by science
so it's really up to the stores and
restaurants what they want to do
yeah yeah i don't know but most i'm
gonna i mean i went to starbucks and i
totally forgot
like i'm not a guy who's gonna fight
this i mean what are you gonna do
and i just forgot no one said anything i
walked down like why the [ __ ] is
everybody back in mass and i was like oh
my god
the mass mandate i went to costco
without a mask when everybody was in
massachusetts
yesterday i'm lying
yeah you're lying i'm doing a little bit
of a lie yeah i just realized i i uh
you're gonna wear a mask i did go in
there and then everybody's wearing a
mask and then i
put one on but i kept my nose out tight
move yeah that was my way of resisting
yeah there's not much we can do no there
but the i went to costco the day before
and everybody had mass and now
i didn't have it was like me and three
other people it doesn't matter i was
like are you kidding me right now i went
to the mall on saturday nobody had a
mask on
nobody nobody nothing good
but the the mandate i find them so
claustrophobic
and and like the worst is for kids we
know you know the effect has on kids and
their lungs and stuff it's terrible
it drives me [ __ ] nuts man yeah i
just wonder if people could just push
back
some did you know how it is especially
in la the the
with new some give them a niche and take
a [ __ ] minute that's the
if they go oh [ __ ] they don't care about
the mass all right let's lock down the
businesses
look that's the history of that's the
history
of our world where where the way you
control people
is it's a gradual you gradually take
that
figure out look at the lockdowns
remember like it's only be two weeks
a year later y'all figure out what
they're going to do
the best thing i heard was the the idea
is well
this could never be this the united
states could never turn into hitler's
germany or stalin's russia oh yes well
they said the same thing
well no yesterday they also said the
same i realized i realized it could once
i realized how
everyone's just go like cheating i'm
like oh [ __ ] dude
well we we're a country that was based
on the idea that you know
the government is the government has to
be afraid of its electorate
the government has to be served at our
whim yeah
that's not what it is it's a refined
democracy you do it through you know the
legends represent the people
yeah not anymore but it's unbelievable
yeah
that's what bothers me so i don't know
yeah the biggest challenge is facing all
of us the biggest challenge
is disinformation both sides
are using disinformation misinformation
mal information whatever you want to
call it [ __ ]
and their narrative to alienate or
isolate the other side so what happens
with that is that we have to have a
we have to have a group of people a
nonpartisan group that can at least we
can rely on to say this is true or this
is not true that's very important like
you can win elections that way you can
you can
you can literally float rumors that by
the time people find out
it's [ __ ] it's too late so we have
to figure
out a way to do that that's very
important that's the new challenge if
you read
what most people futurists and people
are talking about this stuff they're all
like the best
look at the mass mandate now like if you
if if newsom or garcetti whoever locked
us down
with the mass bandit if you would have
had like a town hall meeting
and someone stood up like hey all right
we're down for the mass but why are you
doing it
what science do you have and if you laid
out the stats i think most people like
all right that makes sense
but when the the science doesn't back it
we have the lowest coveted per capita
out of any place in the nation
then it's just like why why are you see
that's what that's all i'm asking for i
want to why
can you tell me why i want a health
bureaucracy
you don't deserve here are the stats
that's my issue newsome goes you don't
deserve it it's unbelievable
i need stats but then how it can't last
too long because think about this
they've sold out the dodgers stadium the
ram stadium they're sold out dude
they're sold out so you're gonna say
well
then also so they're sold out so if we
play in la
you're going to have half capacity but
then full capacity in arizona texas
so that makes no sense but then also if
we're forced to wear a mask
why would anybody get vaccinated so if
your entire push is to scare people into
getting vaccinated
if we still have to wear a mask why
would you get vaccinated they're the
hardest
because because the thing to get
vaccinated was oh we can have freedom if
we have vaccines we get freedom the
problem
we're all vaccinating here but now we're
back in mass so if you're not vaccinated
you're like no do i have to wear a mask
why would i do it there's a large but
there's a large anti-vax movement and
also americans are not going to stand
for the fact that you have to prove
you've been vaccinated right it's a
violation of their privacy
so it's it's it's difficult because what
you're saying is
are you vaccinated people say yeah i am
you don't know if it's true
now if you get on a plane or you go to
other countries like france
you have to show that you've been
vaccinated you've been double vaccinated
that same thing with most of europe the
amer americans don't stand for that
they're just like
nah you're not going to make me carry a
vaccine passport try floating that out
see how far you get
you could float in la guaranteed
passengers in l.a
it's such a shame yeah in l.a and so it
becomes a difficult thing if
you know i do think vaccines work and i
do think we have two billion
and counting people to prove that the
death rate has
fallen drastically because of vaccines
but there are people that first of all
people don't trust the science with that
they don't know what the side effects
are they're worried about
it so the the scientific community
hasn't done a good enough job explaining
well look at that guy my show got
johnson johnson pulled his dick out you
won't be like that
maybe maybe it's from the vaccine dude
that's what i think i mean you're
spreading the rumor i'm just saying the
guy did pull his dog out that's what he
said he had a little patch